the recovery falls into three main areas
of work
first steps to support the system now
given the immediate pressures we face
this winter
second steps to support a whole
assistant response this year to give
better resilience during the summer and
Autumn because as we saw with the heat
wave this summer and the levels of
covered pressure is now sustained
throughout the year not just as in the
past during autumn and winter periods
and third I work alongside these two
areas on prevention
to maximize the step change prevention
potential of proven Technologies such as
work virtual Awards and The Wider
adoption of Innovations such as
operational control centers and machine
reading software to treat more
conditions in the community away from
reaching the emergency department in the
first place
Mr Speaker let me set out the first of
these with the measures I can announce
today to provide support to the NHS and
local authorities now
first we will block book beds in
residential homes to enable around 2 500
people to be released from hospitals
where they are medically fit to be
discharged when combined with the
ramping up of the 500 million discharge
funding
it will unblock which will unblock an
estimated one to two thousand delayed
discharge cases capacity on Wards will
be freed up which in turn enables those
patients omitted by emergency
departments to move towards which in
turn unblocks ambulance delays
it is important however that we learn
from the deployments of a similar
approach during the pandemic by ensuring
the right wraparound care is provided
for those patients released to
Residential Care
which I have asked NHS England to
particularly focus on
so it is the shortest possible stay on
their journey home and into domiciliary
care and indeed it is in the nhs's own
interests for those days to be as short
as possible
taken together this is a 200 million
pound investment over the next three
months
next uh a E's are also under particular
strain
from my visits across the country I've
seen and heard how they often need more
space to enable same-day emergency care
and short stays post emergency
department
so our second investment today is more
physical capacity in and around
emergency departments
by using modular units this capacity
will be available in weeks not months
and our 50 million investment will focus
on modular support this year and we will
apply funding from next year's
allocation to significantly expand this
program ahead of the summer
we are giving trust discretion on how
best to use these units to decompress
their emergency departments so that
might be spaces for short stay post a e
care where there's no need for the
patient to go to a ward for further
observation
or for discharge lounges where
previously they're not being able to
take patients in a bed many of those are
often simply chairs and also additional
capacity alongside the emergency
department at the front end of the
hospital
Mr Speaker the third action we are
taking to support the system right now
is to free up Frontline stuff from being
diverted by CQC inspections over the
coming weeks and the CQC have agreed to
reduce inspections and focus on high
risk providers in other settings like
Mental Health